- [Reporter:] Oh, God. Oh, no. Make sure you're filming this.
- Those fools! They couldn't handle it.
- I was gone 11 days, and the media didn't know what to do.
- Look, our bad, bro. There was just, like, a lot of attention this offseason.
- So, yeah, we started a Hype House!
- [Josh Allen:] Whaaaat!
- Yo, bro, what a glow-up.
- [Reporter 1:] He could be MVP.
- [Reporter 2:] He could be MVP.
- [Reporter 1:] He could be MVP
[Doorbell ringing]
- Cowboys here for our usual hype.
- Oh, sorry, my elder dudes. But, like, are you really still going for it in Year 7?
- The 2022 Gridiron Heights Hype House
was the place to be.
You had the Rams…
...the Chiefs...
- [Sighing loudly]
- [Stephen A. Smith] ...And you had Kyle Pitts specifically
but no one else on the Falcons.
- Uh, hi, I'm Kyle. Is there anything you want me to do
around the house? I can cook, I can—
- The Hype House was classic media.
And not the good kind of media where you talk uncontested to a podcaster
in a tank top but the bad kind where they hurt your feelings.
- Do you even know what TikTok is?
- My favorite show is church.
- Mine too!
- You let Trey Lance in? But he's barely played!
- Hey, kid, think you'll have a breakout year?
[Papers shuffling, whispering]
- Trey Lance says "yes."
- Who's paying for all of this?
- Sponsors!
- And then they made a gargantuan mistake.
They started hyping up an NFC East team.
- [TikTok robot voice:] That feeling when people are high
on the Eagles for some reason.
- Hi, I'm a bearded fantasy podcaster, and, look, we were just hyping anybody. Pretty sure I made up Breece Hall.
- Javonte, it's Russ! Man, this is ridiculous. I dressed up for this. I wore my own jersey!
- But as you learn playing for the Bills, some things are just
out of your control, and life's not fair.
- [Producer:] Do you think there's any one person
to blame for what happened?
- Tyreek, for sure.
- Yeah, I said what I said.
Yo, everyone, listen.
- Wait, Tyreek, don't.
- Tua is like if Mahomes and Brady had a baby raised by a JUGS machine.
- As I've learned very occasionally in my career, there's some things you just can't say.
- So, what happened was the literal weight of expectations got too heavy.
- Broncos Country...
...I tried.
-[Whispering.]
-Trey Lance says the game has really slowed down for him and credits the coaching staff for his development.
-Trey Lance says he actually likes Jimmy staying and breathing down his neck.
-[Whispering.]
-Trey Lance also says the Falcons Super Bowl loss was a personnel failure and not related to play calling in any way.
- Tell your friends at home that Geno does deliver!
- So what I like to do is I gel and then blow dry.
- Ooh.
- Oh, interesting.
- Hey, bet, say less fellow young coaches.
Uh, hey, Kliff, where's Kyler?
- Uhhh…
- See, I prefer to play this game
because it's harder to intercept the grenade.
Oh, wait. I gotta go.
Take my playbook, not my console!
Damn, fam, Imma be late as hell.
Football and gaming combined together…
Ugh, this is like homework.
Oh, hell, yeah, a power-up.
Oh, not cool, fam.
Uh oh, it's the Fighting Brothers game.
- You know, I'm sick of our parents
wearing half your jersey and half mine.
- [All:] There can only be one brother!
- Go left, Mac-Man...go, uh, right Mac-Man! Uh, right!
- Oh, Coach is gonna be hella mad.
- First DeAndre, now Kyler. Whatever are we going to do?
- Everyone, calm down. I coached Mahomes in college.
- Phew, that's right.
- Browns, you piece of s--t gang.
Stop kicking me! Ow. Why are the Browns the one f--king team to make a kick this weekend? Ow!
- Please let me out. I'll limit my screen time!
- Yeah, of course I tried blowing on it. See?
- I'm back, fam.
- You, uh, missed the Chiefs game.
-Oh, look at my boys, Super Bowl Seany for real for real.
Rare Seahawks dub, smh.
Tbh, Russ is kinda mid. So I stay ghostin'.
Yo, Rashaad Penny hits different this year. Sheeesh.
Yo, I deadass do not know what went down at USC. For real for real.
- Davante!
- Aaron?
- Shhh. Listen.
- "Today on Rogan, we're gonna talk
about spiders: Should you eat 'em?"
- Please come back. You complet...ions me.
- Is everything OK?
- Go back to bed. We can't be losing sleep, too.
- Does he take you to big games?
- He takes up less cap space.
- [Voiceover:] After a bad breakup, can this
perennial bachelor find a real catch?
- The trick is just to find a generational talent and then bury all the
annoying parts of your personality.
- Kirk, drive me around.
- I'll try.
- [Voiceover:] The heart only gives…
- Blast them sides, Rodgers.
You look great!
- [Voiceover:] What it can receive.
- Wrong route, you stupid a—
- [Voiceover:] With Aaron Rodgers…
- What's your favorite part about the Pro Bowl?
- [Voiceover:] And, uh, Allen Lazard and some guys?
- Never been.
- I'm Sammy Watkins.
- I dunno.
- [Voiceover:] This fall…
- Look, things change. I used to be a punter,
and now I'm a media darling. You need to be open.
- They need to be open!
- [Voiceover:] Some missed connections…
- [Together:] Why do you even want us back?
- So I can throw to ya any time I want.
- [Voiceover:] Will make you wish you ran for it.
- Goddamn it, guys! Keep your eyes open!
- [Voiceover:] Forgetting Davante Adams.
-I'm just a quarterback standing in front of a receiver asking him to take a paycut for my sake.
And most of all, I hate the way these new guys don't catch the ball. Not even a little bit, not even at all.
I wish I knew how to quit you...and the Packers.
Nah, just the Packers. I mean, Jerry's been begging me to join the Cowboys.
- All right, I've got a weak offensive line, no depth on defense
and a new coach who says he knows Aaron Rodgers.
-That's not what I ordered.
- I thought you could cook anything.
- Guy thinks he can turn The Bronco around, but I heard he flamed out in the big time: Seattle.
- Behind! We are behind!
Chef, hows the au jeudy?
- It's simmering?
- Thank you, Chef. Corner!
- Yes? You know, Russ, you might get further with people if you stopped acting so...extra all the time.
- Heard, Chef.
- Hey man, uh, look we made another mistake in the bread zone.
- What's up, Da Bronco?
- Ugh, this guy.
- Calm down, service isn't for another two hours.
- Two minutes, Coach. People are already lined up.
- 10, 9, 8...
- Third round, 5-foot NUTHIN. You got your bubble water and your fancy headphones. Why are you in charge of the restaurant? I should have let Marshawn run it.
- Fire! Fire everything!
- Fired? Already?
- Remember, separation comes from preparation.
- Whatever you say, Chef.
- Whatever you need, Chef.
- I want all the beef.
- The new special looks like it could be really good.
- Sorry, that's out for like 4-6 months.
- Looks like you're sticking with the usual.
- Done, Chef.
- That's it?
- Well, we couldn't finish it all so I settled for three.
[bell dings]
-How are you gonna make a Bear parody and not make it about the Bears?
We're also miserable people trying to make it work in Chicago.
Smh, I hate this more than I hate the fans.
I mean...
- Ja'Marr Chase, Jaylen Waddle, DeVonta Smith. I'll remember
everyone who's in front of me.
- Bro, we're in a line. It's the Quarter-Season Carnival.
- Men, are you ready to play?!
- Uh, coach? That's the funnel cake stand.
- Don't matter, everywhere I go I compete.
- I'll take the biggest prize ever.
- Uhh, looks like you haven't quite earned it yet. Gotta win a few more games.
- Still? What about him?
- I haven't even won anything, but people keep giving me prizes!
- No Ball Pitts today. Maybe next week, maybe not. Go ahead, write our obituary. See if I care.
- Guys, where are you going? It's all patched up. Good as new.
- Try your hand at Trubi-skee ball!
- Are you gonna play?
- A little.
- My turn!
- Why do you still have a baby voice?
- Last year didn't count.
- Not yet.
- What? But that creep on the Browns gets rewarded?
- Hahahaha. Ahahahaha.
- F--k that elf.
- Just gotta hold 'em off now.
- I'm Jalen Hurts. You can like me and still hate Philadelphia.
- Naaah, I need to see more.
- This year there's a lot of pressure, but it's because everyone believes in me!
- I can hang. Ah, where's our defense?
What can I get for all these?
- Something quite special.
[sad music]
- They just never give us running backs what we deserve.
-You wanna split one or do you want your own?
-Ahahah, ahahaha.
-I don't know what that means but I love this kid's motor.
-Hahahahaha.
-Oh, yeah, he's got that dog in him.
- Danny, what did you do?!
- Oh, God, they think we're killin' it.
- We're not contenders.
Do they really expect me to figure it all out in one season?
- If you're a contender, you can't live in this building.
- We're being set up...by someone we know.
An overly quirky collection of oddballs, losers...
...and whatever the f--k the Seahawks are.
Do we really know any of them?
And why am I podcasting so much?
- That's sneaky interesting. Coming up next on the Bill Sim—
- With our schedule, we've just been taking out the garbage.
- I already spoke to the authorities. We didn't do anything wrong.
- Sounds like someone spread a nasty little rumor about me...again.
- They had to be close to us...someone in our division.
- Hey, sorry, still here. Do you guys know how to get ahh!
- So it's either the Cowboys or the Eagles.
- It was me! We're contenders!
- He's an old man. He doesn't know what he's saying!
- I'm just humble Jalen Hurts, man.
- Are you? Just think about it.
Jalen...Hurts!
- Oh!
- It's in his name.
- Hurts people hurt people.
- Fine! Sure, I hid it in college.
But the truth is, I'm a stone-cold killer!
Arrest me.
- What? What, no, man. You just have to go live with the good teams.
- It's been too long. Let's catch up!
-Comin' up, we'll talk to my buddy Doink about whether the Giants...
...would be better off with a Back like Rex Burkhead.
I'm telling you:
Celery is the nobody-believes-in-us vegetable of crudités.
Brian Hoyer: Ewing Theory candidate?
Is Shaggy from Scooby-Doo the Cordarrelle Patterson of Hanna-Barbera?
- [Narrator:] Eight months after winning the title,
the Rams are nowhere to be found.
And now, Carrie Underwood.
- ♪♪♪ Waitin' all night for morning time. ♪♪♪
- Oh, what happened?
- I went into the bathroom to Zac Yak, and there was a tiger in there.
- What?!
- It's just Who Dey.
- Look away.
If you've seen one hangover, you've seen 'em all.
- Has anyone seen Allen Robinson?
I think you saved him from bears last night?
- How long have we been out? And whose records are these?!
- We need to get back into contention before it's too late.
- I'll catch up with you later.
- Found Allen!
- That's Cooper Kupp. You're looking for a different receiver.
- I have other receivers?
- How much could possibly happen during one party?
- [Matthew Stafford:] F--k them pics.
- You guys lost to something called Cooper Rush?
- You did first.
- Y'all, I think I know how to fix this.
I wanna go for two.
- You have 19, Coach.
- Don't worry, guys. I found a few easy games!
- Where's the last place anyone would expect to find Allen?
- What the hell, man?!
- Is that Allen?
- You piece of—
-I tend to think of myself as a one-man Zac Pack.
And then we drafted Burrow, and there were two of us in the Zac Pack.
Um, and then we lost to y'all, in that big ol' game.
We were like-
-Stop, coach.
It's played out.
- TESTING! CHECK ONE! CHECK TWO! HOT ROUTE!
This is Matt Ryan.
Is this working?
- Stop yelling.
- Just turn it around.
- Well, a few of us have experienced an unusual amount of sacktivity.
So we thought we'd move in together and figure out what's going on.
- Bedtimes for Danny Dimes.
[Glass tinkling, loud crashing]
- Uhhh! Let's ride.
- See? Right there. A chandelier clearly falls on Russell Wilson.
- I would've avoided it, but I've been sleeping injured for weeks.
- And look at this.
[Thudding]
- Slammy Dimes!
- Oh, that's just Coach's game plan.
- Oh, yeah, that's right, Danny.
Really just throw your body around all willy-nilly.
- This is just part of the process.
I'm not even being haunted.
- Sure about that?
[Door creaking]
- Here, Devonta Freeman. Let's just run the ball.
What the—AAAAH!
AAAH! AH! AH! AH! AH! Ah, ah...
I'm giving myself up! Fine, put Ehlinger in.
- So you really think we're being haunted by D-men?
- [Matt Ryan:] Yes! Look.
- [Justin Fields:] It's clearly the ancient D-man, Matthew Judon.
- I called in some protection.
- Indeed, I can already feel the presence of the D-men.
We need to prepare ourselves.
- Out, D-men! Out, Micah Parsons!
- By the power of Trent f--king Williams: I expel you!
[Crashing, glass breaking]
- I didn't throw these pics, I swear!
- [In unison:] IN THE NAME OF ANDREW WHITWORTH...
...JOE THOMAS AND ANTHONY MUÑOZ...
...LET US SEE THE BLIND SIDE.
- AH!
- Sup, Trent?
- Oh, hey, Nick. Y'all are f--ked.
- What do we do?!
- If you're being attacked by D-men, you need to move!
- I don't understand.
- Like, give up and get out.
- OK, listening to teammate feedback, and we're staying.
I refuse to scramble anymore.
- Oh, no. Oh, no!
It's...I'm sorry, who are you?
- Alex Highsmith. I'm having a really nice season for the Steelers.
- You know, our media just doesn't do right by you defensive guys.
- Right?!
- Oooh!
- How do I not have a single weapon? Ahh!
- [Russell Wilson:] What was that?
- I heard nobody believes in me.
- Why are you attacking me?! You're supposed to go through my manager!
- Grrr! Now gimme that.
I wanna watch the film on this one.
- And that's why we must do everything we can to stop the d-men.
- Oh, so scary.
- Aw, man. I hate the d-men.
- This season they gotta go.
- Per Gridiron Heights guidelines,
the best team in the league runs the town hall.
- OK, go ahead, Josh.
- No, the Eagles have the best record.
- Really?
- Are you sure?
- It does feel like we're the best, though, right?
- Order, order!
- We're gonna follow my very easy schedule.
There've been some complaints that this season has been weird...
Two XFL quarterbacks are starting.
Geno Smith is a star.
And people are actually enjoying themselves in the New York section!
- ♪ ♪ ♪  I wanna be a part of it...
...East Rutherford, New Jersey! ♪♪♪
- I'll now open the meeting up to concerns.
- We need a town curfew. I'm thinking, like, 4:30.
- Wait, I have to wear a helmet after my ride is over?
- Hey, everyone, recycle your quarterbacks.
- It's not that f--king hard.
- I don't like how suddenly we're all waking up with aches and pains...
...and how we all thought we could outrun Father Time forever,
but now he draws ever closer with each tick of the game clock.
- Expand the rushing lanes.
- I'm not here to make excuses.
I wrote 'em all down before I got here.
- OK, unless there's any other—
[Doors busting open]
- You all thought you could meet up and kick me out.
Well, I've got all your pets, and I'm gonna—
- This is just a normally scheduled town hall meeting.
- Oh, well, then I guess I'll just sell these back to you, then.
- Why should I have to direct traffic? People should just know where to go.
We shouldn't have to work when it's spooky season.
If other QBs are better, then why don't they debate me?
There's just a lot of pressure to be...
...as awful as the guy who had my position before me.
And another thing!
It is f***ing bulls**t that the Rodgers Rate isn't real.
- Ah, Europe. Home of Florida football.
Nothing says Munich like the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
- [German fan:] It's a famed American
hogskin player!
- Ugh, this happens everywhere I—
- Geno Smith!
- It's Eugene Smith!
- It's all about the team, baby. Isn't that right, Tyler Lockett?
- You know my name? Wow.
Russ always said that's what our numbers were for.
- They should call me Kenneth Dancer.
- Another.
- It's OK, Tom.
- Want me to fight 'em?
- So, get this. I told Geno the route to the biergarten...
...and he actually followed it.
- Woo!
- No one beats me at hanging out.
- [All gasping]
- Carbs!
- Not a single one of my seven rings is worth more than this pretzel!
Let's f--king gooo!
- Don't worry, it's no longer Danger-Russ.
- He has the best foot, so he is the best footballer.
- Nah, nah, nah.
- That could not matter less.
- Ugly Americans.
- So how do you keep getting better as you get older?
- The trick is to get the hell away from New Jersey.
- Hey, look, Gronk!
- Not every white guy with a beard is Gronk.
Oh, wait, that is Gronk.
- Prost!
- [Broadcaster 1:] And nobody showed up today except for the kickers.
- [Broadcaster 2:] Three points?! That's so many.
Field goooooooal!
- And Mariota with a five yard pass to...
...I don't know, I don't care. To take the lead over the coachless Panthers.
[sigh]
Goddammit, I'm Al Michaels, and that used to mean something.
- That's right, Al.
Also check out Amazon's Thursday Night Football Basketball Football.
Finally, basketball players talking over football about basketball and maybe football.
- [Announcer:] Tonight, Gridiron playoff hopefuls will ask our judges...
"Are You Buying In?"
First up: the 2022 Saints.
- Hey, so you should buy in—
- I'm sorry, pal.
- It's a no for us.
- Oh.
- Coach Payton, if you're watching this, take me wherever you—
- [Announcer:] Next up: His dad founded FedEx...
...but will his playoff invite get lost in the mail?
- Pitts' production is way DAHN. Yards? DAHN. Catches? DAHN.
- We're out.
[Buzzer]
- We're looking for a partial buy-in on a wild-card valuation.
- Odell?
- Spin around for me.
Now, dance. Dance for Odell.
- You know, a good sauce can cover up a bad taste.
- Mmm, spicy.
- I guess?
- I'm, like, half in?
- There's a second New York team?
- Hit it! Everyone's laughing with me, right?
- Ugh, they do have really good numbers.
- Thank you, but I'm declining the offer.
- We just said you'll win the AFC South.
- No one deserves to win that division.
- We're in the top percent of the fourth quadrant.
Plus, we just named our new coach: the 2014 AFC finalist banner.
- A proven winner, Mr. Irsay.
- It did beat the Raiders.
- [Announcer:] Coming up next:
"Who Wants to Be a Commanders Owner?"
- All right, all right, all—
- HOV!
- It seems this is the easiest way for me to get a new team.
- Yeah, beg. Beg for me, Jerry Jones.
Ok, hold on. Wait. How many fashion weeks does Buffalo have?
None?!
Rename Jerry World? Odell World.
Do it, old man!
You've gotta be f--kin' kidding me.
All right, pilots, bring it in.
I've retired from the MVP race of my own accord.
- Oh, OK.
- So humble.
- You were clearly forced out.
- Anyway, I'll be your eye in the sky, and this is your flight path.
Do you understand?
- Looks all right to me. Or should I say all left, Tagovailoa?
[Laughing]
- Remind me, Hurts, who's the only undefeated pilot left?
- [Gasping]
I was ordered to stand down by my superior commanders...
...and I actually followed protocol.
[Multiple players gasping]
- This year, it's an airplane race!
- [Aaron Rodgers:] Clear for takeoff in 3...2...1.
- Let's put a little more air under it. I'm not sure we can keep this up.
- Why does everyone keep saying that to me?
- An OG plane for me: the original gangster, Kirk Cousins.
This is so easy!
[Dinging]
- Oh, no! It's the Jets stream.
- I'm just mashing buttons!
- Geno, is that a glider?
- Yes, indeed.
- You know it can only go so far, right?
- I knoooow.
- Coach, we're almost out of fuel.
Do you receive me?
Does...does anyone receive me?
- Where did that come from?!
- Blindside blitz. Goodbye, Frog Man.
- [Rodgers:] Don't worry, folks.
We have taken out the defender.
- Joe Cool here. Losing some visibility. Need a read here.
- One second!
OK, so there's a mountain coming up.
- Fly, Eagles, fly!
- Wheeeee!
- Don't make any stupid mistakes, Josh!
- Nah, come on. Do something reckless.
- That sounds fun!
- Barrel roll it is!
- [Rodgers:] How is this guy still flyin' under the radar?
They're approaching the final turn along Press Row.
And Tua surpasses Hurts!
- Just like at the academy, woo!
- ♪♪♪ Shirtless men settling differences through sports! ♪♪♪
- Not again!
- [Rodgers:] At that speed, they'll never be able to survive the pressure.
The J Force is too much.
- [Reporter 1:] Hurts' flight path was easier.
- [Reporter 2:] Can Mahomes do it without Tyreek?
- [Reporter 1:] I still don't think Tua's that good.
- I can win MVP!
- I have won MVP!
- Look out, look out, look out!
- Let's just avoid any unforced errors.
- It's like we always say...
- You can't make an omelet without breaking a few tables.
- Uh oh, snow.
- Better move to Detroit for a week. Jinx!
- Ah, jeez. You never get used to seeing a team's chances die, do yah?
- Kirk, man, why you gotta sound so corny all the time?
- I'm not dead yet.
- Ah, you betcha yah are there, guy.
- So, someone killed the Packers, and all they took was
a briefcase with the title to the division in it?
- Can you think of anyone who would have a grudge against Aaron Rodgers?
- [Together:] Yes.
- Op, there he is.
- We got a runner.
Are you a killer?
- Not in real life...
...but in my fantasies.
- Oh, well. Who could care about that? Goodbye!
- There's someone sticking out of the woodchipper.
- Oh, another spectacular catch there, Justin.
- I was just making some Packer kneecap for dinner.
By the time we got to them, they were already dead.
- Why a woodchipper?
- Because it's hardcore.
- Wait, stop!
Oh, sorry, it's getting late. I don't shoot so well when I'm tired, eh.
Oh, give me a sec.
- Oh!
- I'm sorry, sir. Who are you?
- Your coach, Kevin O'Connell.
You know, one of McVay's little buddies?
- Ohhh. Hey, Coach.
So, you're saying we, the humble Midwestern Vikings...
...have been killers the whole time?
I just don't understand it.
Op, just ran over the Pats.
- You like the radio, there, coach?
- [Radio Announcer 1:] Be advised: the Vikes are on the run...
...and they do have weapons.
- [Radio Announcer 2:] Yah, but if I know the Vikes...
...they never get too far.
- [Radio Announcer 1:] Hahaha, you're right! So, it's just a matter of time.
- Op, that's enough of that, there.
- Welcome to the golden hour!
Where the ugly look beautiful and the beautiful look like everyone else.
- It's over for y'all once we finish animating Brock Purdy.
- Oh, little old me in a photo? Haha.
Sure, I guess. Haha.
- Oh, stop it. You're 8-4.
- Where are the Titans?
- We're behind Brian's hat.
- [All affectionately:] Briaaan.
- Lamar's out for a few snaps.
Oh, wait! I'm getting a tweet alert!
STFU y'all be cap—OK, this is very problematic.
Cut to commercial!
- [Producer:] We don't do that.
- Make an exception!
Let's go to a quadbox to check in on all four NFC East teams.
- YELLING! CHEESESTEAKS! HEART!
- No, no! Group photos always get me in trouble.
- That monster on the Browns is back.
- Ahahahaha.
- Where's our NFC South rep?
[Sad violin music]
[Regal trumpet]
- Make way for Mike White, the king of New York!
- Hi! Hello!
- [Together:] I hate the Jets.
- Oh, man. Up top Justin Herbert has entered the picture,
while Geno Smith is also making a move.
- Sorry I'm late. The breaks have been, like, weirdly bad lately.
- OK, we're losing light. Smile.
[Camera shutter]
Well, at least the AFC looks nice.
- Oh no, where is everyone? What's going on?
- Calm down, Kirk. It's just nighttime.
- Prime time, where the Cowboys shine!
Oh wait, the tide is carrying me away!
- [all:] Someone grab Jerry!
[Thumping on roof]
- [Jimmy Garoppolo:] Another great drive, babes.
Kittle, babe, you GOTTA condition that long hair.
We got enough split ends.
- Whoa, whoa, not again!
- Nah, that would be too dark for a kids program.
See you in the postseason, Brick.
- Woo, it's a physical sport. Next man up.
- CMC drives sleigh.
This Santa Clause seems like it's on very shaky legal ground, no?
- You're in charge of distributing the footballs now.
- We don't like to think about next year here in Santa's Clara.
- Deebo will help you with anything you need.
- Oh, great. More things for me to do.
- And this is Bosa, our Sackmaster.
- Haha, sack.
And my voice is deeper? Oh no, is this a horror story?
- Look, it happens all the time. See?
- Guess I gotta buy some shoes to fill.
- Oh, boy. This is a rough game.
- Don't mind if I f--kin' do.
- Flac-ho ho ho! Look who's came crawling back?
- I didn't even get hurt!
- Keep an eye on the internal clock on the sleigh.
You have three seconds to deliver each ball.
- Hut, hut.
- Nothing over five yards, OK, Brock?
- Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell Brock.
Jingle around the-
-Hey.
- He does exist.
- They told me I was a lineman, not a frontman.
- This is our big chance!
Every single person from the media showed up.
- I have a major announcement.
It's the Eagles!
[Audience cheering]
The football team.
- [Audience:] Aww.
- Jingle bells, jingle bells...
[Snickering]
♪♪♪ Jingle all the way. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- Oh, my God, they're better than the Chiefs!
- Eaglemania swept the nation.
And who managed that s--t but me, Nicky Sirianni?
- I heard you're looking for a little of that Nashville sound.
- So, crikey, the head 'ranger wanted to add some joeys.
- He means Sirianni added some folks.
- Things did get a little weird when the band entered their Batman era.
- ♪♪♪ Dark Knight,
Bruce Wayne. ♪♪♪
- They were the Eagles, but then they added bats.
It was too many animals.
- You've changed, Jason. I'm supposed to be the hot brother.
- ♪♪♪ You're a mean one, Mr. Snyder. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- We got upstaged by the f--king Commanders.
- ♪♪♪ Daboll, Daboll, Daboll.
The refs threw the game our way. ♪♪♪
- Maybe I could play lead?
- Quiet, Tony Pollard!
Zeke's the star.
- We had to get back to what got us there in the first place.
- No rules, just right.
- This one goes out to all the haters.
♪♪♪ We wish you a Merry Christmas! ♪♪♪
- [Doug Pederson narrating:]
I washed out of Philly.
This strange land was my last chance.
OK, we can work on that release.
-  [Pederson narrating:] They'd had bad experiences with outsiders.
- OK, let's make this place look and feel like Ohio.
- [Pederson narrating:] They spoke in a foreign tongue.
- Duval!
- [Pederson narrating:] But they embraced me as their own.
- Let me show you...the way of the cat teams.
- Aaaaah.
- [Pederson narrating:] For the first time in eons, all four clans had a chance.
- You either die a hero or live long enough to become a Panther.
- We just gotta attack the Pack.
- We also need the Seahawks to lose to the Rams.
- You nerds with your mythology.
- Why are you all blue? Cats aren't blue.
- I'm a Zac cat, y'all. Meow.
- [Pederson narrating:] But the Titans were coming for us.
- Wait, who's driving this thing?
[Banging, splashing]
- Dobbs?
[Squeaking]
- We need to think like them.
- Man, what the hell are you doing with your ponytail?
- Hold the line! Wait.
What's in the water?
[Splashing]
Oh, God, these special effects are TOO realistic!
- For years the bird teams have kept the cat teams at bay.
Must the Eagles clan do everything?
- Yeah, our bad, fam.
- Fix. It.
- Alright. Hey, Coach Kingsbury.
See that cliff?
- [Kingsbury:] No, no, no, no. I am Kliff.
Woaaaaah!
- [Murray:] Oh, whoops, I pushed you out.
- Thank God I'm missing the playoffs so I can focus on research.
- Are you down and out and unsure what to ride into the playoffs?
At Chargers Auto Group,
our bandwagon is huge, and this bad boy is very empty.
- It's all electric, and it comes in dope colors.
- Not sure about budget?
- We're flexib—
- Exceeding expectations with a QB you've talked yourself into:
the Throwback Giants Bandwagon.
It can be 2008 again.
- You name it, we got it! All the bells and whistles.
- A strong defense!
- Check.
- A franchise quarterback.
- Well...
- OK, yeah, our cars are gonna break on ya.
But that's why we got a...
[Alarm blaring]
- Next One Up policy. Woo!
- That's right. We've got seemingly unlimited options.
So come on down to the Niners.
- [All:] We'll get there somehow.
- I've got three words for you: No money down!
Right, Lamar?
- I'm not selling s--t until I get my commission!
- Yo, if you didn't support us from day one, f--k off.
#NoNewFans. Wagon's not for sale.
- Yeah, she's got some miles on her, but she's as reliable as always.
And don't you ever forget that.
- I really wish you would stop asking about our safety features.
[Alarm ringing]
- What's up, sports fans?
Sure, we're out of it.
But do you really wanna go with a fancy playoff dealership?
Or do you wanna watch me lift that sedan?
- Do not, I repeat do not, come down to Arrowhead Automotive.
There's no more space on our bandwagon!
That's right, our bandwagon is full and closed,
because everyone loves us so much.
- Thanks for the drive, Zeke.
- OK, Dak, enter the casino. You just need to win one—
- OK, tell Dak he just needs to win—
- OK, tell Kellen Moore to tell Dak to win.
- [Announcer:] Interception!
- [Jerry Jones:] Careful, you're surrounded by serious threats.
- So, uh, my dude. What are the rules?
- Oh, I thought you had done this before.
- I call.
- I ain't call back, though.
- Wait, I have to play Tom Brady?
The Bills get to play against Skylar Thompson.
- Go fish!
- No, no, no. Go Bills.
- [Dak:] And I don't even know who is left for Baltimore.
- You're Ray Lewis with a fake moustache.
- Man, I said I'm No-Name Johnson.
And I lettered at Minnesota Southern.
- OK, daddy needs to recoup massive crypto losses.
- Looks like Brady's tell is that every time he's inconvenienced,
he destroys a tablet.
- Stupid thing givin' me bad cards!
[Banging and shattering]
- Call.
- Ah, once again, bested by my enemy...
DVOA.
- How'd I do?
- Wait, wait.
- [Together:] Is this kid, like, really good?
- Hey, man...
- [Together:] I love your hair. Jinx!
- There, there. You're coming with me.
- OK, let's see your cards.
- We won.
- Please give me some privacy as I publicly mull retirement.
- Shaken not stirred, what the f**k is that?
All we have is warm Yuengling and water.
- Um, I can make you a burger if I can find you a grill.
Oh, they left.
- You know, I used to coach the Eagles.
- Very cool.
- I'd like to order a private plane.
Destinations Miami, San Fran, Vegas, Foxb—
What is that noise?!
- It's easy money, and you barely have to play.
- Yeah, but Indianapolis?
- Beer me, Aaron!
[Crashing and fizzing]
- Looks like that one hit..."LaFloor." Hahahaha.
- Why is your body making those noises?
- I'm doing a laughing, Tom.
I'm happy! Turns out during the playoffs,
everyone else stays in Gridiron Heights and gets along.
Have a cold one.
- Why? To be relatable on late-night TV?
- Everyone's welcome. Isn't that right, Russ?
We also got catering.
- The Jets are happy to sponsor the offseason dance contest...
...for the 12th straight year!
[Cheering]
- I wish Super Bowl expectations were this low!
- Could've been worse.
- I love it here.
- Look, look, watch.
Du...falllll.
- It's all good. I'm about to be Kirk Cousins rich.
- Look, the kickers parade's starting.
- [Crowd:] It's OK, we blame Dak!
- Sorry we weren't here sooner.
We accidentally beat the Bucs.
- Is it really not all about winning?
- Yo, we're trying to rest for the playoffs that we're still in.
- Our...apologies...
- Losing sucks!
- Everyone, get them!
- [All:] Aaaaaah!
- So, uh...how...how's Davante?
- Oh, you, uh, didn't hear? We broke up.
- Oh, wow, that's...I'm sorry to hear that.
- Yeah, well, think he never got over an old flame.
Go to him, Aaron.
[Romantic music swells]
- But-
- I wouldn't be Derek Carr if I didn't love love.
Now, go to him before it's too late.
[Door opening]
- I know what the f--k I'm doing.
I'm allowed to be here.
- There's vomit on your sweater already?
- Little Caesars hot and ready.
- Stop rapping about vomit. We're up next.
- ♪♪♪ Oh boy, looks like you've been slain
by my No. 1 guy with a high ankle sprain! ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- [Together:] Good game. Good game.
- There's nothing young white coaches love more than "8 Mile."
- NFC, let's get ready for the final battle.
- ♪♪♪ Lance, Jimmy G., gave the rock to Purdy.
Mr. Irrelevant and Imma still hang 30. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- ♪♪♪ You had four QBs, whoops now you've got none.
Oh, what an offensive GENIUS, another Deebo run. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- ♪♪♪ Got big dreams, and think you're getting closer.
What's that? DPOY Nick Bosa. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- You said Toby Keith was performing.
- ♪♪♪ Hate to pan the man, but he's just a nepo baby.
Hey Shanahan, how many snubs you get from Brady? ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- All right, playas.
Winner is decided by whoever gets the loudest.
- How does that make sense?
- Aaaah. LOUD SCREAMING.
- ♪♪♪ Nicky Sirianni says Nicky Sayonara.
31-7 is the final score-a.
Fly Eagles fly, bye Niners byeeee. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- Philly wins!
[Knocking]
Oh, no, the stripes are here! Run!
[Whistles]
- Everybody else got dues to pay.
Little Zac got a gig 'cause he met McVay.
Hamburger eats, giant playsheets,
Ya gonna get beat, I got Reid receipts!
- Your weak-ass rhymes don't affect me.
Could've been friends, you're my Bienemy.
Joe Cool in the pocket making you pay,
Got all the homies back in Cincy yellin':
Oh, Who Dey?!
- Take your time, we've got plenty of—
[Explosion]
- Nevermind, hurry up.
- What's going on, Dad? I mean...Andy Reid.
[Zombie attacking, growling]
- No. Sweet baby Nick Foles.
- I think a mutual change will benefit us both!
- I agree! I'm leaving on good terms!
- Yo, they say the kid is special.
- Oh, wow. The world sure is interesting.
What does this do?
- Show him, Pat.
- A high ankle sprain?
But he's still moving.
- I'm immune to bad things.
- We need to take him to Arizona.
- But it's been overrun...
...by Philadelphians.
- Go Birds.
- Wow, another beautiful day in the zombie apocalypse.
- [Together:] Oh, shocker.
You're gonna make us the bad guys?
Typical anti-Philly bias.
- They're connected into one toxic hive mind.
It's very scary.
[Zombie growling]
[Clearing throat]
- Sorry, I'm hometown hero Haason Reddick.
[Glass cracking]
- Scramble!
- Run! I'll block!
- Do you still do that?
- I'll try.
- Aaaah! They sound so weird.
- Woo! Jabroni thought he got me!
- You've been infected...with Eaglemania.
- No, no, I can stop this jawn! I mean...thing.
- He's changing.
[Zombie transformation sounds]
- Hey, Jabronis...go Birds.
- It's Eagle Kelce! Run!
I think now might be a good time to give me some weapons.
Here I am!
Look, I slayed.
- Aaah!
- Illegal hurting of the main character.
- I know it's not cool to say, but this kid is getting annoy—
- This should be a fun level! I mean part.
- Look, they've got runners...
And All-Pro wideouts.
- I thought those went extinct.
[Thundering footsteps]
- A Hurtser.
- Even though I'm a zombie, I'm still very hot.
- Every now and then, you do need some defense.
- Chris Joooooones.
- Damn right, I'm on fire.
- Aaaah.
- [Announcer:] Wow, two young guys making the most of a tough situation.
Speaking of finding love in a hopeless place,
stick around for "Fedra Presents: The Rihanna Half-Fight Show."
- E, A, G, L...
- M, N, O, P.
- A battery?!
- Time's up. Oh, wait...
This watch is busted. Uh, time's yours.
- Tyreek? Tyreek!
If you find this, then I've gone to a better place.
Or at least Miami...hehehe.
I used to hate the world,
But I was wrong.
Because there was one person worth saving...
Me!
I wonder how I write him back!
- I did it. I finally did it.
Andrew Reid won a Super Bowl!!!
- What a fun, easy sport.
- I'm telling you all, this has happened before. Look.
- [Phone speaker:] Andrew Reid won a Super—
- OK, time for that darkness retreat.
- We are stuck in a script of a show that just keeps repeating itself.
And its name is—
I wish I could see things clearly.
- Try this. It's a little untraditional.
- Say no more.
Well, guess I'll go die on the Jets with my Wrangler jeans.
Woah, some drink.
- What's he smokin', huh?
[Laugh track playing]
- Expired Gatorade from when I was in St. Louis.
- Back to work!
JK, maybe this year I'll go back to work.
[Awww]
- LOL!
- Is it always like this?
- B.O.B., will you be my O.C.?
- Woah.
- Can't wait to definitely play football this year.
- Stefon Diggs is disgruntled.
- Finally, one of my conspiracy theories is true.
- Welcome, remember to dress up as your—
- They're reusing scripts! We already did a whole Brady thing.
- [Together:] Oh, yeah.
- We're not trapped!
Next year will be the Bills' year.
- Next year will be the Bills' year.
- Oh, my gosh, he's right.
Wait, where's Aaron?
- People will come looking for me if I miss McAfee!
Woah, a secret door.
- Aaron, I'm so sorry I left you.
- I know now...it wasn't your fault.
[Paper printing]
- It's next year's scripts.
Saquon joins the Chiefs?
OK, don't hate that one.
- Hello, I am the Script Writer.
I decide which storylines are epic enough to happen.
- But free will! Why are you repeating everything?
- OMG, spectacular catch, Davante.
The thing is, people only want the same six scripts.
Chiefs good. Refs bad.
Chargers lost in a weird way.
- [Together:] But we wanna win.
- Then press the fire emoji.
Destroy the next 100 years of football scripts.
Choose chaos. That is, if you think that's what people really want.
- F--k you, script writers.
- Timeout! I like the routine.
I underperform one year. I overperform the next.
I get paid. Repeat.
- But, Kirk, don't you wanna win?
- I'm not sure I can.
- Do you know why I'm so confident?
- The cigar?
- Cuz you're really good at football?
- Cuz you're super hot?
- Because when the abyss stares at me,
I stare it the f--k back.
- Kirk, I believe a lot of wacky things.
But I have to believe any of us, even you, could win.
[Beeping]
[Alarm sounding]
- Deleting scripts for Seasons 8-100.
- [Josh Allen:] Wheeee!
- Alright, time to approve next year's scripts.
What? Where are the scripts?
Davante and Aaron need to get back together,
Clammy was supposed to come back in a big way.
We were finally gonna do an Avengers Endgame parody.
Every episode was gonna go so viral!
No! The unknown!
Anything can happen! Oh, god, what if the Lions are good?
[Door creaking]
- Hello?
Is someone there?
- Uh, you're at a...
darkness retreat?
- What the hell is a darkness retreat?
He'll never—
- Shh.
- Ah, yes! A darkness retreat!
And you must be my conscience.
- ...Yes.
I love player empowerment,
but this season, Aaron got maybe
TOO empowered.
- So as punishment,
we're brainwashing—no,
strongly suggesting...
that he join the Jets.
No offense.
- No offense is literally our problem.
- Fine! I'm going to the Jets.
So long as...
- He wants us to sign the ghost of
Jordy Nelson,
get McAfee hired at WFAN,
gift him that Joe Namath jacket...
- Much like my personal hero,
Scarlet Witch
after she turns evil,
I have eliminated all player autonomy
and
trapped them in a Gridiron Heights
of my own making.
I mean...
we renovated.
- [Producer:] Isn't that just the same Gridiron Heights
but with a monorail?
- What?! No!
It's a new day in Gridiron Heights.
We're restructuring
with some old favorites
in exciting new places.
- Just win, baby.
The tuck rule was a fumble.
Josh McDaniels is a football genius.
- Oh, and you're gonna love
the direction we take Derek Carr
in this season.
- I'm fixin' to get me some etouffee
down there by the Quarter, now.
- Some players were easier to
reprogram—I mean convince—than others!
- Um, Jalen,
some people were talking shit
saying you'll never play for the Dolphins?
- MAN! I'LL SHOW THEM.
- Before long, we'll have the
Gridiron Heights
I've always dreamed of,
with exciting new characters!
- Hmmm,
I think I could mold you.
- Some characters will have to be...
retired.
- Goodnight, Ezekiel.
I loved you the very most.
- But I didn't retire.
You can just re-sign me!
- I'm happy we got to an agreement.
- Gridiron Heights:
It's normal,
good and free of scandal.
- YOU CAN'T MAKE ME SELL!
- TEAMY DISTANCING HIMSELF
FROM SNYDER!
RAWR!!!
[Crashing]
- This is your fault for not having an agent.
- They said they're sending me to a team upstate
where I'll have
plenty of room to scramble!
- They'll be back for us any minute now.
Annnnnny minute.
- Baltimore's gonna come a-calling,
just you wait.
- Nexts years my year.
- I could make a comeback.
- I'm Ryan Leaf. Get me out of here.